what up I'm Noah Cyrus I'm here at
BuzzFeed and today I'm gonna be trolling
my trolls how could Noah Cyrus sell her
tears for twelve thousand dollars when
even the tears of Jesus was okay well
because I didn't actually saw my tears
for $12,000
there was no bottle of Tears it was a
joke and then somebody tried to scam
GoFundMe and all of the money is getting
rear-ended so joke's on you
ha does anyone else's ears bleed would
knowing Cyrus is on the radio because
sane at least I'm on the radio
ah Noah Cyrus seen wearing a 1d onesie
that is a disgrace to our fandom I am
not pleased 1d is my life
where's that mean
Chipotle is my life One Direction is my
life no Cyrus sounds like she really
needs to blow her nose oh good I'll blow
my nose with that tweet I was at urban
looking for these parent pants and I was
about to house was leaning near the
counter if they had it but she turned
around and it was Noah Cyrus I totally
fit oh my god I probably could have
shown you where the pair of pants was I
love Irving's too much I feel like that
was just funny that you aren't a toy
equal in this day and age you can say no
us see is so cringy and people are not
going to know if you're a dog on Noah
Cyrus or Noah sentient teeny
who is that oh that's super sexy dude yo
know you're looking at this you're super
sexy so cool I don't mind and
last one just said this spongebob mean
to my boyfriend six times on the road
now we're broken up I feel you know
Cyrus ah at least it wasn't a naked
picture of Charlie puth thank you guys
so much for watching make sure to go
check out my new EP called good cry look
phaidor's I'm making money moves
[Music]